anytime we feel anything negative
anything negative what is the illusion
that I have bought into I love the idea
that
um or the visualization or embodied
feeling of that if sort of anything
feels uncomfortable or
feels bad is because whatever that thing
is is out of resonance with your true
self that's right your true self is
never that so if you don't feel good
it's because you're out of resonance
something is putting you in a position
yeah that you have to do something or
say something or be someone and it's not
who you are yeah you've bought into a
self-perception that is not in alignment
with the truth of who you are so so for
instance deep down on the surface it
might be this person flicked me off in
the interstate and now I'm mad
but deep underneath all the layers of
ego what really might be going on is I
feel powerless and I'm upset that I feel
powerless whatever it is whatever that
negative self-perception of the root is
that you think reality is proving to you
that negative self-perception of feeling
either powerless or Unworthy of love
or you know some of the other like I'm
not free that's another big one not
having freedom those are not in
alignment with the truth the truth is
you are a powerful being you are
unconditionally loved you are love
itself
and you are completely and totally free
but when you lose yourself in the idea
of not being free that hurts that
triggers fear when you lose yourself in
the idea of being shameful Unworthy of
love that sucks because it's not true
and so whenever we have that negative we
can honestly look inside of ourselves
and say where do I have fear and what
negative self-perception has the world
seemed to prove to me the illusion of
the world I might add has it seemed to
prove to me
is real it's just it's not really
fundamentally real but it's giving you
the opportunity to be really in your
face
and really give you the chance to to
identify with potentially these
perceptions and play with them what kind
of powers do we have here I get that
we're infinite beings we're of like all
these things but
like doesn't feel practical what are our
tools here and what maybe what are our
tools right now and what do we where are
we stepping what are we stepping into
because it does feel like we're stepping
into something we're moving into another
level of us that has access to more of
something so what are our tools here
right now and what should we be working
to cultivate right so on a practical
level we are constantly affecting
reality physical reality all the time
like we're nudging the probabilities all
the time I know most people believe in
an objective material world it's only it
only appears to be an objective material
world
it's actually probabilistic in nature
Our intention does affect outcome all
the time so that's just one thing so
it's not it's not predetermined it's a
probabilistic reality where intention is
constantly nudging all the time all the
time
so I'm just pointing out that mechanism
but but what's the power behind that
mechanism and that is intent our true
power is our intent
what are we really intending In This
Moment how are we how are we really
using this moment you could say the most
direct way to comment that question is
what is your relationship to this moment
are you making it an enemy
or are you in love with it is it in love
with you
if it's not in love with you and you're
not in love with it that's okay find out
where you bought into something that
made it an enemy oh because but I but I
went through years and years of trauma
and I was I'm you know whatever the
story is that immediately Rises up in
anger because the ego is pissed you know
it raises its righteous Fist and it says
I have good reason to call this universe
cruel and me a victim are you willing to
let go of that actually and find how you
actually do have the power to even feel
that negative fear whatever it was you
locked away whatever it was that all
those years of abuse or whatever it was
seemed to prove to you are you willing
to actually go feel that and honor
yourself love yourself enough to
actually meet your own experience all
the way
now that may sound indirect to your
question but it's not it's not indirect
because the quality of our experience
directly is reflective of the quality of
what we've done within ourselves as
Spirit when you go into these dark
aspects of yourself of something you
fear or something that you're jealous of
or something that you're angry about
um
you know you have to go through the pain
it's like
on a micro level that's what's happening
here on Earth but on a macro level you
go I'm going to go into this Incarnation
to learn this thing to elevate to a
higher level out here and it's just sort
of just bigger and smaller versions of
it you know but they're all the self
there's an important Point here that I
think is often missed so sometimes when
we hear a conversation like this we
think oh there's something I need to do
and the thing I need to do is to go you
know face my fear isn't do these things
okay that's true but but there's
something deeper than the doing and that
is your actual willingness
to feel or to be or to do whatever
and I'm pointing that up because you
mentioned avoiding pain willingness to
feel the pain
this willingness I'm talking about means
for the pain that you've buried away
your whole life this is not about
avoiding that anymore if if you really
want to open up all the gates it's about
actually being willing to go feel the
pain
willing that means you no longer make an
enemy you say you know what I feel
powerless to this but I'm going to feel
it anyway I'm gonna go see I'm gonna go
into the dark closet and see is this
thing really going to destroy me or not
and that requires feeling
it's a very personal and genuine and
real process it's not about you know
like as humans on the surface we're all
about activity do this activity get this
result tell me what activity I can do so
I can get away from this pain that I I
have this is more than activity it's who
you are it's it's the actual quality of
choice that you make and the universe
that's what it's watching it's not
watching necessarily the activity
it's watching your willingness to admit
your your your issues to own yourself to
own your pain to feel your pain to
actually help the person next to you to
actually be willing to actually choose
Joy even though that might mean that you
have to be vulnerable to be full of joy
right now to be a little kid and run
around and play in the sun you know what
I mean like that's a quality of being
choice is all I'm saying it's not
primarily about an action where are we
going are are humans not going to be
humans as we know it or something
completely different like yeah where are
we going I'm understanding your
questions I mean where are we going as a
physical species but I don't want to
comment in the context though that we're
not human
I know that sounds totally crazy I know
that we're I know that sounds totally
crazy but we're not human you're you
you're the you that feels like you to
you that's who you are and you just you
think that you means human really deeply
but that's not that's not that's not
what you are so where are we going we
are the players We Are the souls we're
going even beyond the limitation of The
Human Condition we're going to
into experiences I can't possibly even
imagine yet name but as a physical
species the physical species will end up
over time reflecting more and more that
Limitless nature of spirit it just might
take what we would consider a long time
right which is not a big deal to Spirit
linear times of creation anyway it's not
a big deal
do you remember other lives that you had
non-human or well I know I've had
hundreds of other Incarnation
incarnitive experiences but I only
remember Snippets from a few I remember
a couple that are non-human and I
remember one as a human woman so if I
get curious and I try to investigate I
usually get this gentle nudge like no
you don't need to go see that right now
and I'm fine with that you're like okay
no problem you know I'm Christian right
now so I know that I've had other
experiences
um and when I say I've had other
experiences that's really important it's
not because sometimes I think when we
think of reincarnation
we think oh those are other people and
I'm them no it's you it's like if you go
do something on Monday night and then
you go to something on Tuesday night
like you go to dinner one night go to a
movie the next night go to a race car
track the next night whatever it is
still you going to each of those
experiences there's not really a
different person you might be a slightly
different person on Tuesday night than
you were on Monday night and you might
be a slightly different person on
Wednesday night than Tuesday night
that's how it is as a soul we have one
experience and then we have another
experience but it's the same you so
you're never not going to be you
processing trauma and going into these
dark spaces that we're afraid to go and
becoming a different person or being
afraid almost that you'll become a
different person it's like you'll never
lose your essence ever absolutely like
you'll your your your home frequency
that people feel won't ever change it's
really just how you change how you feel
in that frequency like that's the crazy
thing about growth and like becoming
more of an observer and not getting so
wrapped up in things and getting so
pulled and torn and victim in that and
oh my gosh that and Division and it's
like you actually your reality sometimes
changes there's definitely no bones
about it like sometimes some things in
your reality change but for the most
part you just feel better in it yeah so
what feels not good
is when you've associated with things
that you're not
right that's what feels not good
fakeness
uh negative self-perceptions that aren't
you
you know that's what that's what doesn't
feel good the the real you is full of
you're joyful you're a joyful being you
are you just it and I like you know you
might you might say no no no
I have this long story like I said all
this history that proves to me that
that's not true that's okay
you've had that experience now now what
you're still you you're still the joyful
you underneath all those layers always
yeah it's it's really a message of hope
I mean we just we come so far deep into
this Human Experience we really get lost
in the story and it's an opportunity
it's a gift and we've become so lost now
that we kind of made it into a little
bit of a nightmare sometimes you know
what I mean but now that we're here we
we still haven't we never lose who we
really are the question is what do we do
now in this moment with remembering even
just a little bit when I say remember
who you are I don't mean you need to
have a big like big old you know Grand
experience I'm talking like when you
look at the Sunset and you feel the joy
in your body
or you feel like oh my gosh like life is
good
and notice how that is not just a
feeling or an idea it's your very stuff
your very nature your being your
Consciousness itself actually is that
reflecting back to you in the form of a
sunset that's all yeah we're we are all
family actually there's no such thing as
a stranger strangers only happen when we
have the illusion of separation and then
we don't remember and we don't feel
connected so we think external people
that we have no history with are
strangers that's what we call Strangers
but truly we're all connected we're all
brothers and sisters every every one of
us not just humans but animals
Trails it's the same there's not there's
not a big difference between like I know
that sounds super crazy because oh my
gosh now we're talking about ETS but the
soul has many different opportunities to
Incarnate not just human not just Earth
okay Earth Earth is precious it's very
unique I I was able to feel and know the
incredible unique preciousness of Earth
but it's not the only show in town it's
not the only class you can go to it's
not the only place there's other systems
with incredibly different vibrations not
just in our entire universe but there
are entire other universes available
we're us were you and you're you and I'm
I mean that's what we are we're just
playing human
do you think that we'll have true real
contact and knowledge and confirmation
of extraterrestrials on Earth or is that
yeah I think it's inevitable yeah yeah
have you ever have you met that did you
no I have no I have no direct experience
with what we would call an ET I do have
one
memory of what I suspect was probably a
I don't want to label it in any way but
an intelligent civilization that was not
human I think I have at least one
experience in that but other than that
I've had no direct experiences myself
with what we would call
et's I have interacted at times with
other being other people's guides or
their deeper selves but how to draw a
big distinction like I said it's not
really the form if you like this clip
and you want to hear the whole episode
click at the bottom of your screen